My father has taught me many valuable life lessons.
One lesson in particular, which came from his father, my grandfather, is that a
problem well defined is half solved.
In other words, if we can clearly define the nature of a problem, we're halfway
towards finding a viable solution.
Undoubtedly, the problem of evil is one of the greatest challenges raised against
the Christian faith, or really against any belief system.
But before we ask the question why might God allow evil or how does a Christian
faith make sense of evil, let's first make sure we clearly define evil.
Not too long ago I was in getting my hair cut and I overheard a conversation next to
me that quickly caught my attention because the conversation was about the problem
of suffering and evil. And a lady said this she said I think evil and good are
equal but opposing forces I had to jump in as soon as I heard this
because it seems to me that she gave a faulty view of the nature of evil you see
good and evil are not two equal opposing forces rather evil is a corruption
of good you see you can have good without evil but you cannot have evil
unless you first have a standard of good that can be corrupted consider an example
from C.S. Lewis, a former atheist, by the way, that he wrote in his classic book,
Mere Christianity. My argument against God was that the universe seemed so cruel and
unjust. But how had I got this idea of just and unjust?
A man does not call a line crooked unless he has some idea of a straight line.
What was I comparing this universe with when I called it unjust?
As Lewis noted, justice and injustice are not equal and opposite forces.
Injustice is parasitic upon a standard of justice.
You cannot call a line crooked unless you first have a standard of a straight line.
Consider another example, let's take truth and lies.
Truth is when a belief matches up with reality.
In a sense truth is telling it like it is.
A lie is when you tell something that intentionally doesn't match up with reality.
It's intentionally saying something that doesn't tell it like it is.
You see, you can have truth of which no one tells a lie but you cannot tell lie
unless there's first truth. Lies are a corruption of truth.
This idea that evil is a corruption of good is evident in the broken
world around us. Divorce is a broken marriage.
Racism results from broken relationships where we fail to recognize diversity.
And addiction results from taking something meant for good, food, technology,
medicine, sex, and corrupting it for something bad.
Simply put, evil is when things are not the way they're supposed to be or they
are the way they're not supposed to be.
Understood this way, evil assumes that there is a way the world in fact is
supposed to be. But this only makes sense if there's really purpose and intent and a
mind and design behind the world.
So raising the problem of evil actually assumes and implies that there is
a way that the world is supposed to function.
but atheism cannot account for design or purpose or the claim that the world is
supposed to be a certain way and the reason is because on atheism the world just is
it popped into existence from nothing and through time and chance and the laws of
physics the world just arranged itself in the way we see it today so ironically
if an atheist complains about the problem of evil they have to assume the theistic
worldview to do so.
Pantheists also can't consistently raise the problem of evil.
And the reason is because on pantheism, as you'll remember, distinctions are
artificial. There really is no distinction between me and you, mind and matter,
yesterday and yesterday, good and evil.
So according to pantheism, you can't have a problem of evil because evil doesn't
exist it's an illusion properly understood the existence of evil is one
good reason to believe there's a standard of good and if there's a standard of good
the best explanation is that there's a God now this doesn't explain why God allows evil
we'll get to that but at this point it's critical to realize when we properly define
and understand the nature of evil.
It's one good reason to believe that God actually exists.